Alright, so we understand at this point how to use these decision trees, but
this is a class about machine learning, right? So we need to figure out
how to make those decision trees happen as a result of processing a set
of training data. So, it's not clear to me how we're going to make that leap.
>> Let's see if we can figure it out
together. So, I'm going to play a game with you, Michael,
and if we do the game well. Then I
think we'll have an idea of what a good algorithm
might be for actually building a decision tree. So
we're going to play 20 questions. You're familiar with 20 questions?
>> Right, that's the game where I'm allowed
to ask yes/no questions to try to guess
something that you're thinking of, and if I
take more than 20 of them, then I lose.
>> Right, okay. So, here's what I'm going to
do. I'm going to think of a thing, and,
you ask me questions and I'm going to answer them and we'll see if you can guess
what thing I'm thinking about. Okay, I've got something in my head.
>> The first question, the typical first question
is it animal, vegetable or mineral but that doesn't
seem like a yes/no question, so is it, is
it an animal, or like a, a living creature.
>> The answer is yes.
>> Alright, is it a person?
>> Is it a person?
The answer is yes.
>> Is it a famous person?
>> Is it a famous person? That's a
deep philosophical question, but I'm going to say yes.
>> Is it a famous person that we both know in like directly.
>> Oh, who we both personally know directly, I do not believe so.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the answer is no.
>> Is it a living person?
>> Living person, no.
>> So it is a dead, famous person. Is
the person famous for, say being in the music industry.
>> The answer yes.
>> Did this person live during the 20th century?
>> The answer is yes.
>> Is the genre of music that the
person was associated with, say hip hop or rap?
>> No.
>> Is the person a singer?
>> Singer? Yes.
>> Male or female, is the person female?
>> Person female? No.
That's ten questions, Michael.
>> Yes, the, the clock is ticking down, but I feel like I have narrowed it
down quite a bit at this point. Did
the person die since you've become a professor?
>> So, say in the last How long have you been a professor?
>> Too forever it sounds like feels like. Let's see,
recent death. And I'm going to say the answer is yes.
>> Is the person's name Michael?
>> The answer is yes.
>> Alright, alright, I think I'm on to it. Is it Michael Jackson?
>> No.
>> Woo hoo!
>> Of course, it's Michael Jackson.
>> Alright, Thriller.
>> Yes, Michael Jackson is the answer.
>> Alright. So that was, that was very fun. And
I'm very glad that I was able to solve it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's not clear to me how, this
is going to give us an algorithm for building decision trees.
>> Okay, so let's think about that for a second. So you asked a bunch
of questions, and you asked them in a
particular order. Right? So, here's a question I have
for you. Why was the first question you
asked me whether it was an animal or not?
>> well, it seemed like I needed some way of
narrowing down the space, and so I wanted to get
as much information out of that question as I could
to try to make progress towards figuring who it actually was.
>> Right. So,
animal is the first question and it was because it narrowed things down. So,
your goal in asking questions was to narrow the possibilities, right?
>> Sure, right because I only have 20 questions and
then I'm, you know I'm out of it, so if I
asked questions like You know, if I had said--started with,
Is it someone named Michael, that would have been really bizarre.
>> Right, and if the answer was no,
it's not clear that it would tell you anything
at all. So, actually, that's an interesting point. You started
with animal; you could have started with Michael. And
if I had said yes, that would have told you
something. But if I had said No, it wouldn't have told you hardly anything at
all. Right? So animal is a better attribute, or
feature, to ask about than Michael as a first question. Do you agree with that?
>> Yeah, because it could have been like a stapler or something
like that and then I, the Michael question would've been pretty silly.
>> Exactly. So what about persons? So first you
asked about animal. Then you asked about person. Why person?
>> Right, because, because again it seemed like of the space of possibilities
that I could think of person would help kind of again narrow things down.
That I'd if it was the answer was yes, I would be able
to focus there. If the answer was no I could focus some place else.
>> Exactly. And so I
think in fact we could, we have a general statement here.
That each one of these questions. Person, famous, do we know this
person, personally, so on and so forth. All make sense because they
further narrow down the possibilities. And that bit about further is important.
Because it implies that the usefulness of a question
depends upon the answers that you got in the
previous questions. So even though Michael is not a
particularly good first question to ask, it's a perfectly
reasonable twelfth question to ask or however far down
it is, given that you already know this person's,
this is an animal, a person, a famous person
we don't know personally who's not living, who's into
music, etc., etc., etc. Okay, that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So I think then, we have the hints of an algorithm. So let's
try to write down that algorithm and, and see if it matches with our intuition.